來了各位
Sora終於開放給台灣的付費用戶使用啦
這款玩具遇水會變大
我現在就示範給你看
沒人吧 爽啦
你們的咖啡是3歲小孩做的嗎 小寶我就跟你說會被投訴
我盡力了
今天這集我們帶大家一次看懂Sora2的操作
以及分享我們實測5個好玩的應用
嗨各位又是我AJ 什麽都先不談 我們先鼓掌
Sora這個產品問世之後真的是神龍見首不見尾
一整年都像女朋友一樣不知去向
非常的迷樣
終於在今年的Q4 最近Sora2正式下放給一般的用戶使用
今天我們會先從基本的操作開始
再給大家一個超實用的Prompt提示框架
最後跟各位分享5個有趣的Sora影片生成玩法
讓你秒變影像創意大神
好康分享時間 拿YouTube官方AI證書的機會來啦
我們跟YouTube learning連鎖推出了兩門AI課程
第一堂是少年們的AI簡報影音大作戰
這堂課能讓國小還有國中的學生可以一次學會如何輕鬆上手Gemini
以及用它製作出自我介紹文
簡報 講稿
最後做出一份專屬於自己的AI影音大作
第二堂是AI神隊友 Gemini實戰互動課程 這堂課不管你是高中生
大學生 上班族 或者是純粹想要上手AI的人
都能夠從這堂課學會Gemini AI的操作應用
上完這堂課之後呢
都可以從連結 前往台灣數位文化協會的認證網站進行投稿還有考試
通過之後呢
將要獲得全台唯一冠名的YouTube Learning專屬證書
別等了趕緊一同來拿證吧
簡單搜尋Sora這個關鍵字
找到之後 跳過這些奇怪的廣告
你找到這個Sora.com
點進去之後 就按開始
好的這邊非常非常的簡單 左邊這邊有一個叫做for you的這個功能
然後可以看到
那左上角這個選單里面呢
在手機版里面還有個可以讓你選這個喜怒哀樂的心情的選項
就是你可以去根據這個影片的這個情緒去找適合你的影片
我覺得他是有點在做
就是有點類似IG這樣的一個瀑布流這樣的一個形式來去讓你看到
就是網友們創作的這些技巧
這些影片點進去的時候
其實你不一定能夠看到完整
他下的整個給Sora的提示詞 網友寫是這樣寫
但是他里面的提示詞有沒有寫的很複雜
這件事他不會在這個地方秀出來給你看
當然下面這邊你可以輸入你的指令
然後來去要求他去做一些這個影片生成
那你也可以上傳圖片
然後作為一個參考資料根據你的圖片去生成這些影片
那右邊這個設定 現在就可以選擇
你可以選擇是直式的影片或者是橫式的影片
然後長度大概現在是10秒或15秒
那因為我的這個帳號沒有花到200塊美金那個專業版我這個是plus版哦
那一個月20美金的
話他一天15秒只能做兩支 那如果你改成用十秒的話
那一天可以做的指數應該就會多一些些 目前是30支
但是我不知道你看這只影片的時候現在的支數有沒有變多
那你可能很好奇說 那我可以去找
對不對 你現在找這個放大鏡然後去搜尋
但是這個時候選你只能找people
你沒有辦法找關鍵字
所以你只能找創作者 比如說Andy有很多Andy
那這個Andy Franco 1.1k follower
所以你就可以看到別人的賬號
可是假設你竟然要找一個MacBook的這個影片然後變成一隻龍之類的
你是又沒有辦法用關鍵字去尋找的
你去找的時候你只能找到賬號
那另外呢
主頁上面有一個功能按鍵叫做Cameo
那這個Cameo
你可以去跟他做聯名
所以當你今天要去跟這個賬號合作的時候去你可以去@他
那你就可以去用他的
上傳上來的那個有一點類似Avatar之類的這個肖像的臉
直接去生成其他的影片
我覺得這個還蠻有趣
當然你必須要上傳你自己的肖像
而且你要同意大家去做這樣的一個合作
所以我覺得之後應該會有一堆按讚互粉在那個機制
就像IG這樣子大家會互相加朋友
來去互相拉抬能見度這件事情
那當然再來就是最下面這個就是我的這個個人的主頁啊
你可以自己去新增你的這個大頭照
然後 這個叫做creat character
那就我們目前的測試
你可以傳一些圖片上去變成一個動畫的這個character
你也可以把你自己變成一個Avatar這樣的一個角色
可是如果你要去用你自己的臉
那你必須要用手機
他是要用類似掃那個face ID
就是你用手機去證明你自己不可能隨便拿一張馬斯克的照片
然後就說要去生成馬斯克的character
怕被深度偽造這樣的一個機制
另外呢在拍的時候
他為了避免你拿著手機去偷拍你的在睡覺的男女朋友去生成他的Avatar
所以你在拍的時候
你還要一邊念出螢幕指定的數字
他要確保你是一個真人而且有認知真正常的能耐
然後還去確認之後你才能夠用你的臉去生成一個你的這個Avatar
好那接下來我們就直接進入我們的重頭戲
那到底我們要怎麽樣給Sora2下提示語 你可以去這個open AI的cook book
這個網站
那這個網站我們之前已經講過 但是這個網站里面最新的一篇
這個10月6號出了一個叫做Sora2 Prompting guide 的文章
所以你可以在這個文章里面找到各種各式各樣的這些
這個跟Sora的這個提示語的技巧
這個啊你往下卷你會找到這個叫做這個
那這東西翻譯成中文呢
就是你要去做場景描述
去描述角色是什麽
然後場景是什麽
天氣什麽氛圍等等這些細節
然後你要下風格你要下攝影的一些比如說鏡頭啦參數啦
你要去下一些構圖角度
比如說中景特寫低角度
然後你要去下鏡頭的那些焦段 然後光線跟色調
氛圍動作
甚至是對話 你也可以去把台詞寫進去
再來就是你要去定義他的背景音效
這一切的這個框架你都可以根據你的需求來去寫出來
好所以呢
我們可以請ChatGPT幫我們寫這樣一個提示詞
請作為Sora2的提示詞工程師寫出
我將翻譯提示詞改寫成符合我需求的提示語
我希望的影片主題是 一只貓在滿是狗的脫口秀
瘋狂的講嘲諷狗的笑話
範例提示詞長這個樣子就是剛剛OpenAI官方提供的
送出 我就可以把這個提示詞把它複製起來
然後回到Sora
我們再去做一次的生成 你看這樣看起來不就是很多很多的細節
你就可以根據你自己的需求來去調整成你自己的一個好生成的提示詞
你知道狗最喜歡的運動是什麽嗎
追自己的尾巴
因為只有這樣你們才覺得自己跑得快
我看著都替你們累
所以我們來分享5個我們再去做測試的時候
同事發想出來的一個有趣的這個案例 你看這狗有夠可愛
還穿太空衣喔 這是在拍電影嗎
厲害哎 肥到像饅頭 啊阿就是他
追很久了終於抓到了 說真的要領獎金哎
好對話都是台灣中文看起來沒有問題
然後街道的這個背景也很是很明顯的
就是OpenaiAI的模型還沒有辦法正常顯示中文字
一個黑白監視器的畫面
他剛是不是有罵髒話?
2025年11月4號 是準的
菜價貴到發瘋 阿嬤我也會押韻
九十塊的高麗菜 吃起來像燒金紙
青蔥變成滷鑽石 洋蔥看到都流淚 老板還說要不要再加
但我問你是要搶劫
我相信下次颱風來的時候就會有人拿這個來講菜醬太貴了 熱血日本漫畫
各位猜的出來這個我們傳了什麽照片上去嗎
沒錯就是三井壽
所以 熱血日本漫畫 每個格子的外框都固定
人物角色都有動態 每2秒換一個分頁
然後我們沒有告訴他這些台詞還有他講話那個對白 可是呢
你可以試著把這段影片丟去給日文翻譯的AI哦
那你會發現他出來的這個角色講的這些旁白什麽的都是對的
我覺得這一塊真的顯示出來的還效果真的是也是不錯的
(日文)
那最後我想要談一個很有趣的小功能叫做Remix
那你看到這個叫做
進擊的巨人 不對 進擊的肥宅 那這東西怎麽做出來的呢
很簡單你只要回到Sora的這個探索
你看到別人生成了這個影片
點開這支影片之後你會看到一個叫做Remix的按鈕
你就可以通過這個Remix點一下之後加上你自己要加的一些調整的提示詞
他就會去把這一支影片根據你的提示詞再去做二次的混搭
以上就是我們這支影片
不知道這支影片 對你來說有沒有幫助呢
希望你在影片下面留下你的心得來跟我分享一下你怎麽使用Sora2
那我們今天的影片就到這個地方
下次影片再見嘍拜拜